we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p this
voicemail is very timely in the context
of impeachment in the context of what we
expect to be an acquittal of donald
trump along party lines in the senate
let's take a listen hey David names
landed Letterman from East Tennessee hey
Landon I just had a question about
impeachment and all this is that I mean
I I'm not trying to play the importance
of voting but if voting is the only
means of dealing with a corrupt
president yes in terms of the way Donald
Trump has lived his life at all rights
and why do we have a system of justice
because it just seems pointless to me
that that's the only recourse get back
to me on this ya know Lyndon you're
completely right I mean this is a this
is what I've been saying for a while the
Moller investigation was never going to
remove Donald Trump go back and look at
my videos from I don't even know but
April of 2017 I said if you're waiting
around for this to remove Trump it's not
going to the 25th amendment possibility
the cabinet you know if you're awaiting
a right that this is clearly a guy who's
impaired either from in a medical sense
or in a colloquial sense it's not going
to work impeachment we know it's not
going to remove Donald Trump the volume
it's violet it's not going to remove
Donald Trump so the question Landon is
asking is when we all have to contend
with which is are our systems of checks
and balances too much subject to the
whims of the party that is in control of
them I think the answer is yes I don't
believe that the founders ever
considered when they put these in place
that a president would simply ignore
them the checks and balances are only as
good as their enforcement and our
ability to have them enforced and the
ability is basically zero zilch
right now so while I don't like to
accept that this is the reality
Landon's right that the one way the one
opportunity to give Trump a consequence
like a parent would tell their kid
if you do this you're going to have a
consequence the only opportunity is
voting Trump out in November of 2020 if
he's re-elected there will be no other
consequences during his second term and
he will serve that second term and then
leave he's not going to be indicted
after he leaves the White House forget
that if people are holding out hope for
that but there's one opportunity and
it's simply saying at the ballot box we
reject you we reject you by such
overwhelming numbers that even foreign
interference and voting machine nonsense
and all of the stuff and verging voter
roles we reject you by such overwhelming
numbers that even those things can't
keep you in the Oval Office it's one
opportunity
Landon's right it's a sad reality but
that's the reality we're dealing with we
are going to talk on the bonus show
today about the black Texas teen who was
told to cut his hair his dreadlocks in
order to walk at graduation what is all
that about many people outraged we will
also talk about new research where it
appears as though we figured out why
stress turns people's hair gray okay we
will discuss that and in addition to
that New Jersey is mandating severance
pay for workers facing mass layoffs and
that in and of itself is triggering a
lot of people who I guess don't think
that the workers deserve severance pay
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show become a member at join
pakman.com to get instant access the
impeachment coupon code is impeached 50
we are at 103 new members we're using
the impeach 50 coupon code help us make
it a hundred and four we will also be
continuing our mmm endless marathon
streams of the impeachment trial of
Donald Trump if you're listening to this
we are probably streaming right now come
find us on YouTube and twitch we will
otherwise talk to you on the bonus show
or on tomorrow's program